pas
[Musique]
le conseil départemental de ses agents
lors d'une cérémonie de remise de la
médaille d'honneur départementale ce
mardi 14 mai à la villa du département
pour les agents du nord et delonte mais
aussi ce jeudi 16 à villèle pour ceux de
l'ouest et du feu au total ce sont deux
cent soixante treize agents qui ont été
récompensés pour leur professionnalisme
leur rigueur et leur dévouement
le sein de la collectivité 49 ans et
demi alors il restait deux mois après
quarante ans après avoir travaillé aux
en est
avec des packs trop et c'est après la
mort ma maman et
quoi occuper
et mes petits frères et soeurs donc
j'avais décidé
allez ensuite de poser ma demande pour
travailler comme assistant familial en
76 il disait passe temps familial il
disait nourrissent et ben voila depuis
76 jusqu'à 2016 à la retraite l'autre
sur concours en 1984 trente-cinq années
tandis qu'alice d'une collectivité très
importante
plus de 5000 agents je crois le
président bedie je croise amis lesquels
se 1700 à peu près ce qui est énorme
j'ai eu la chance moi lorsque je suis
rentré
d'être affecté au comité des oeuvres
sociales donc pu voir cette collectivité
plutôt de l'intérieur du côté des agents
ce qui était en très bonne chose
j'ai passé vingt ans cozad un peu en
tant que administratif et par la suite
pour une année supplémentaire en tant
que président de cette association c'est
un bel événement au niveau de deux de ma
carrière et ensuite je suis venu à la
com j'y ai passé à peu près les 15
autres années restantes
là ça représente seulement une
reconnaissance dans la continuité du
service public puisque j'étais avant l
éducation nationale est transféré comme
tous les agents de collège à porter 2009
c'est important de reconnaître que ces
agents du service public se donne à fond
bsb ambitions pour cyrille melchior
président du département il est
essentiel de valoriser ses agents et de
les récompenser pour leur compétence et
leur savoir faire et ceux qui
travaillent au sein du département de la
réunion
eh bien il faut savoir exprimer notre
reconnaissance pour le travail qui est
fait parce que c'est un travail qui
n'est pas facile notamment le travail
social dans nos services
et je tiens le soulignait le département
pour plus poids des réunionnais eh bien
nous agents sont des agents remarquable
je tiens à exprimer mes remerciements à
l'ensemble des agents et mes sincères
félicitations à celles et ceux qui ont
été décorés ce matin d'une médaille bien
méritée
parmi les deux cent soixante treize
médailles et 29 ont reçu la médaille
d'or 68 celle de vermeil et sans faute
en phase la médaille d'argent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]